cas françois pour les matiz journaliste
spécialiste de l'europe bonsoir françois
paul et mathis merci d'être avec nous on
vient de le voir là charles saint qui
consolide son statut de favori la
succession de daniel américaine mais on
connaît le système électoral un petit
peu compliqué en allemagne on veut dire
aujourd'hui que rien n'est fait
oui ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
dimanche ce sont des députés qui sont
élus députés au bundestag donc on élit
des partis on élit un ordre dans les
mares qui seront élus on n'élit pas un
chancelier d'une chancelière seule une
coalition possible entre ces deux
parties va pouvoir générer la
désignation d'une chancelière faut pas
oublier par exemple que la chancelière
angela merkel a mis plus de moi trois
mois quatre mois avant d'être désigné
comme futur chef de gouvernement donc ce
qui va être connus dimanche soir sait
quel est le parti qui arrivera en tête
probablement ce sera le spd est derrière
la cd ou est encore derrière les verts
mais il faudra que les coins de leaders
de ces partis se désignent pour une
possible coalition soit le leader du spd
qui devrait arriver normalement en tête
va réussir à former une coalition
probablement avec les verts on viens de
l'entendre et peut-être aussi avec
d'autres partis soit ils n'y arrivent
pas ce qui veut dire que même à me
l'achète même étant minoritaire même en
arrivant en seconde position pourrait
éventuellement composer une coalition si
d'autres parties acceptée le gouverner
avec lui donc c'est très compliqué mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est
particulièrement difficile en allemagne
c'est avant vous serez il y avait le
parti démocrate ou les céder ou c'est à
dire des conservateurs qui s'allier ou
ne saviez pas avec lui et c'est comme ça
que les majorités se faisaient ce qui
est différent cette année c'est que deux
parties ne suffiront ça veut dire que
probablement il faudra trois parties
d'où les verts joueront un rôle
absolument déterminant trois partis pour
former une coalition c'est là tout
l'enjeu de ce scrutin ce qui veut dire
que vraisemblable andy l'argent ne
connaîtra pas le nom
du futur chancelier de la future
lancelier reconnaîtra simplement l'ordre
d'arrivée dans l'élection des différents
partis et un autre enjeu françois pour
les métis et celui de la participation
parce qu'à ce jour il semblerait que les
allemands ne seront pas tous
complètement passionné par ces élections
il ya encore un taux de mobilisation est
un taux d indécision assez élevé selon
les sondages en tout cas
faut tout reprendre en fait que ces
trois parties et surtout les trois
leaders il faut comprendre que les
allemands se trouvent face à des choix
de personnes c'est quelque chose de
nouveau avant traditionnellement les
réellement voté pour des partis mais là
les personnes et personnalités ont pris
une importance particulière dans cette
élection ce qui veut dire que ces trois
personnalités elles se ressemblent
quelque part elles sont européennes
toutes trois elles ne remettent pas en
cause les fondements de la politique
étrangère allemande sur l'ego sujet
elles sont d'accord et puis sur les
autres sujets
l'immigration on en a quasiment pas
parlé pendant ces élections alors c'est
très difficile effectivement pour les
citoyens allemands de se repérer dans ce
manque de différence puis lorsqu'ils se
sont affrontés ces candidats se sont dit
je ne pourrais pas gouverner seul donc
il faudra que je trouve une à
correspondant pour trouver une majorité
ce qui veut dire que la campagne n'a pas
été aussi opposés aussi pas agressive
mais aussi faux dynamique que pourrait
être par exemple une campagne en france
où on sent que les candidats à la future
présidentielle sont beaucoup plus
opposés sur beaucoup de sujets en
allemagne non en allemagne on a
essentiellement parlé de deux sujets
dans cette campagne d'une part le climat
les ménages climatique et d'autre part
relance de l'économie et donc tous les
autres sujets à son passé a dit ne
frappe ce qui explique en partie le fait
que les citoyens allemands non au moins
a été mobilisée qu'avant sur toute
élection ça veut dire vous écouter parce
que nous aussi à nous autres français
nous sommes à sept mois d'une élection
présidentielle
que vous écoutez les enjeux ne sont pas
du tout les mêmes semble-t-il pourtant
on est très voisin c'est vrai que en
france on parle de climat cern de
relance économique certes manseur
beaucoup aussi de sécurité en tout cas
les médias nous en nous en parle
beaucoup
c'est exact en fait en allemagne les
partis extrêmes c'est-à-dire d-link à
gauche à l'extrême gauche ou l'afd qui
est à l'extrême droite sont suffisamment
faibles pour ne pas finalement modifié
considérablement la campagne et donc il
n'y a pas de véritable opposition je
rappelle encore une fois qu'en allemagne
pour gouverner on ne peut gouverner
quand coalition et celle cognition
finalement a interdit de manière à bas
un peu plus musclée sur des enjeux de
société par exemple donc c'est vrai que
sur ce plan là la campagne en allemagne
diffèrent considérablement de ce que
l'on peut attendre l'année prochaine
pour la campagne présidentielle en
france ce qui est vraisemblable c'est
que il mentait pas la chose qui est le
leader du spd va probablement arriver en
tête après la déception qui qu'a connu
armin laschet tu as la tête du ch et des
houes et ses multiples fausses et multi
que le paf si on peut dire fait qu'il a
été profondément affaibli comme
maddalena berlocq dont on attendait
beaucoup qui était la verte la candidate
verte mais qui suite à des accusations
de plagiat mais je suis peut-être elle
aussi à des gaffes ne s'est pas montrée
comme une candidate chancelière à la
hauteur et donc aujourd'hui
paradoxalement c'est le ministre actuel
des finances de angela merkel qui se
trouve dans la position d'être le favori
notamment parce que c'est celui aussi
qui a débloqué la situation dans
laquelle souvenez vous c'est lui qui
avait finalement permis à l'allemagne
d'accorder son accord pour un emprunt
européen ce qui était tout à fait de
nouveau pour le mind et donc c'est
quelque chose qui va falloir prendre en
compte vraisemblablement ces eaux-là
chose qui devra essayer de former cette
coalition mais encore une fois rien
n'est dit et le soin et dimanche soir il
n'est pas impossible que nous n'ayons
pas d'informations suffisamment tangible
pour désigner et chancelier ou une
chancelière avec dans ce cas la chance
ou le risque c'est selon que angela
merkel reste encore un petit peu au
pouvoir quelqu'un n'est ce pas c'est
exact c'est exact la constitution
allemande fait en sorte que à nouveau
chancelier mais désigné que lorsqu'il
peut apporter la preuve qu'il dispose
d'une coalition de gouvernement il est
temps que cette preuve d pas apportées
c'est l'actuel chancelier ou chancelière
en cas d'espèce c'est angela merkel qui
devra continuer à gouverner il est tout
à fait possible que angela merkel soit
encore chancelière d'allemagne dans la
période de noël par exemple pas lui dire
adieu trop vite alors merci beaucoup
françois houle et mathis d'avoir été
avec mon nous avons remporté votre
analyse